Prof: As we approach the
end of the semester we also,
naturally, approach the end of
the Quixote,
and we move on to the
consideration of other works of
his,
as well as reactions to his
works by two major writers,
Kafka and Borges.
That will be next Thursday.
Today, I will talk about the
end of the great novel,
and next class I will devote to
those other works,
and also to Cervantes' death,
but before,
I want to address two topics
that have sort of fallen by the
way side;
humor and Cervantes' self
portraits, following my little
essay in the Casebook
that you have--presumably--read.
Other than slapstick,
or the slapstick kind of humor
that we find occasionally in
the Quixote,
in the episodes at the inn in
Part I,
for instance,
as well as some of the
scatological instances,
such as the time when Sancho
defecates in the fulling hammers
episode.
Cervantes' humor is broader,
more encompassing,
sophisticated,
and it is laced with irony.
By irony I mean that there is a
benign detachment,
a discreet perspective from
which humanity is being seen in
contrast to the mad hero.
Don Quixote's madness allows
the narrator and the reader to
appreciate everyone's folly.
No one is safe.
Not the priest,
the duke, graduates like
Sansón Carrasco,
and not even the narrator
himself.
Sancho's wisdom is another
measure by which to judge other
characters, presumably better
educated.
He is not just the wise fool,
funny,
the funny man who stumbles upon
truths by chance,
but the possessor of natural
reason,
which allows him to be right
when others,
who are well-read, are wrong.
I believe that the one who best
encapsulated Cervantes' humor
was the late Lowry Nelson,
who was a professor for many
years, here, at Yale.
He writes in his Cervantes,
A Collection of Critical
Essays,
in the introduction he writes
the following,
and you have a handout in which
to follow my reading of this
quotation.
It's the one-signed Lowry
Nelson, Jr.:
"As depicters of the human
condition,
both Shakespeare and Cervantes
belong to the select company of
those I would call universal
ironists,
as distinct from tendentious
ironists.
Universal ironists contemplate
the world with a kind of gentle
resignation and compassion in
full knowledge of both the
grandeurs and miseries of human
life.
Among them I would number
Chaucer, Chekhov,
Kafka and Svevo [Italo Svevo].
Tendentious ironists view the
world from a programmatic
stance, connoting accusation,
bitter protest and meliorist
reformation of human ills.
[Meliorist, meaning to make
better].
Among them I would include
Flaubert, Ibsen,
Hardy and Mann.
The distinction is only
approximate but nonetheless
significant.
Neither attitude is
qualitatively superior or
justifiable,
though it is perhaps the
universal ironist who can view
mankind with greater tolerance
and understanding.
It is he who can encompass a
broader span of human types and
human experiences.
It is he who can best present
the inviolability and unique
essence of the particular and
the individual.
It is precisely this ability in
Shakespeare and Cervantes to
create particularized essence
that leads us,
their readers,
to draw the general conclusion
to see the individual as
representative.
Hence, the seeming plenitude of
humanity we find in such odd and
peculiar figures as Don Quixote
and Sancho Panza,
not to mention Sansón
Carrasco,
the curate, Marcela,
Ginés de Pasamonte,
and others."
Particularized essence means
here, I think,
that individual objects,
and specially characters,
are full within themselves,
in their being;
they're round.
This is why details are so
important in the Quixote.
By the plenitude of humanity
Nelson means the foibles,
weaknesses and also the
grandeur of these figures,
as he says;
their mistakes,
their bumps against the real
are funny, and counterbalance
their virtues.
Irony resides in the fulcrum,
where the two are added to each
other, without canceling each
other.
With respect to Shakespeare,
though, though I agree with
Nelson, I want to reiterate what
I have said in previous classes.
There is a level of despair in
his plays that is never reached
in Cervantes.
Cervantes has a gentler
perspective on the human
condition and a more optimistic
one.
I'm thinking,
of course, of Hamlet.
And I'm thinking,
of course, of King Lear.
So much for humor,
although much more could and
should have been said throughout
the semester.
Now, as for the self portraits,
I included those texts because,
as I explained in the book,
the format of the
Casebook called for an
interview with the author in
question,
and since Cervantes was not
available I thought that it
would be best to include this
text,
that would make a good
substitute.
I toyed with the idea of
inventing an interview with
Cervantes,
but I didn't think I could get
it past the editors at the very
staid and serious Oxford
University Press.
The things I would like you to
remember from my little prologue
are these: that individualism
lead to portraiture in the
Renaissance,
and also individualism that was
also aided and helped by wealth;
that perspective,
the development of
perspective--
think of Alberti,
of whom I have mentioned many
times along the semester--
allowed for more realistic
particularized kind of portrait,
showing significant details of
the face and body,
not all necessarily
flattering--although,
of course, those who paid for
the portraits wanted to be
flattered;
that the first self portrait by
a painting that we know of was
Albrecht Dürer,
in which he shows his piercing
eyes and fine hand,
the instrument of his craft;
and that this self portrait
announces and anticipates is
better the one of
Velázquez in Las
Meninas,
where he appears in a prominent
position,
full of energy and self
assurance in the act of
painting.
Then there are the concomitant
self portraits by Cervantes,
which are characteristically
self depreciating.
In one he talks about the
changing color of his hair;
in another, he talks about his
missing teeth and so forth;
so he's self deprecating,
particularly with regards to
the effects of time on his body.
What I would add today is that
we should see those self
portraits in relation to the
1605 prologue to the
Quixote and Cervantes' self
presentation as author.
It is certainly different from
Velázquez,
whose much more self assured
and self promoting obviously,
but perhaps this is the effect
of the different mediums that
they are using,
painting and literature,
but most likely it is a
difference in their
personalities.
Now, we get to Don Quixote's
return home.
The novel's plot with his
repeated returns home suggests
that life consists of going and
coming back,
sort of a compressed
Iliad and Odyssey
together,
and is made up of a series of
apparent repetitions,
re-encounters and reprise.
Both parts end with the return
home after a sally;
actually, there are three
returns.
It seems as if Don
Quixote, the whole novel,
is suggesting that in fiction
there are two basic plots:
one going out and the other one
come back;
one the Iliad and the
other one the Odyssey.
That's too simplistic,
but there seems to be that
suggestion in the combined two
parts of the Quixote.
What do these repetitions
reveal?
What do we learn from them?
Perhaps that to live is to live
again,
and that life includes the
remembrance of life,
as Proust would discover and
exploit over two centuries later
in his great novel À
la recherche du temps
perdu,
Remembrance of Things
Past, in English;
a great work that I hope you
have the chance to read some
day, if you haven't yet.
That is why we approach the end
by returning to the beginning.
In the process,
Cervantes has,
once again,
underlined that reality has
become fictionalized in Part II,
independent of Don Quixote,
and that his own hero belongs
to the great fictions of the
ages,
to the great characters of the
ages.
I have been mentioning this,
and I will repeat it now when I
comment upon some passage.
Cervantes also,
in this return--and I will go
over it--
underscores the nature of the
Don Quixote's victory,
which I mentioned with regards
to Aeneas in the Aeneid.
So, as he returns,
Don Quixote finds a character
from the apocryphal
Quixote,
Don Álvaro de Tarfe.
I have read Avellaneda's
Quixote,
and I can assure you that this
character appears in that
Quixote.
It is as if his memories had a
life outside of himself in
literature.
Cervantes is,
of course, again,
poking fun at Avellaneda,
but the way he does is full of
other suggestions,
as I mentioned in a previous
class,
and I referred to the work by
Stephen Gilman.
The first and clearest is that
Don Quixote lives in a world of
fiction that intersects that of
Avellaneda's fiction.
It is the ultimate proof that,
in this Part II,
reality has become
fictionalized,
as I mentioned earlier,
without the help of Don
Quixote's fantasy,
it is out there,
already fictionalized.
Characters from two different
fictional books meet,
and one asks the other to sign
a document,
a notarized document to testify
that the book in which he
appeared was false and that he
is the real one.
This is enormously funny at a
very sophisticated level.
The document is crucial,
as legality would be the
ultimate way of guaranteeing
that a fiction is real.
Cervantes is perhaps
remembering here the legal
document out of which picaresque
fiction issued.
Remember that I mentioned
several times,
the picaresque begins as a
deposition,
a legal document of a criminal
addressing a judge,
and so this is not the end of
Avellaneda,
because, as you remember,
after Don Quixote regains his
sanity,
he asks to be forgiven by
Avellaneda for having induced
him,
enticed him to write such a bad
book.
So then they come to the last
inn, remember we talked about
the first inn,
and now we get to the last inn.
The first inn in Part I,
remember, with the prostitutes,
and the fish that is served,
and all of that,
where he's made a knight.
Here we get to the last inn
which he does not confuse with a
castle any more.
At the last inn,
where Don Quixote and Sancho
lodge on the way back their
room, contains representations
of Helen of Troy and Dido.
The passage,
I believe, is one more example
of Cervantes' awareness of the
importance of his creations.
This is on pages 927,928 in the
Jarvis translation and it goes
as follows:
"He was lodged in a ground
room [he, Don Quixote]
with painted serge [serge is a
kind of base kind of cloth,
not very...],
instead of tapestry,
as it is the fashion of country
towns.
In one of the pieces was
painted, by a wretched hand,
the Rape of Helen,
when the daring guest carried
her off from Menelaus.
In another, was the history of
Dido and Aeneas;
she upon a high tower,
as making signals with half a
bed sheet to her fugitive guest,
who was out at sea,
flying away from her,
in a frigate or brigantine.
He observed,
in the two history-pieces,
that Helen went away with no
very ill will,
for she was slyly laughing to
herself;
but the beauteous Dido seemed
to let fall from her eyes tears
as big as walnuts.
Which Don Quixote seeing,
he said,
‘These two ladies were
most unfortunate in not being
born in this age,
and I above all men unhappy
that I was not born in theirs:
for had I encountered those
gallants,
neither had Troy been burnt nor
Carthage destroyed;
since, by my killing Paris
only, all of these mischief had
been prevented.'
'I hold a wager,' quoth Sancho,
‘that ere it be long,
there will not be either
victualling-house,
tavern, inn or barber's shop,
in which the history of our
exploits will not be painted,
but I could wish they may be
done by the hand of a better
painter than he that did
these.'"
Unquote.
Anyone who has been to Spain,
especially to Madrid-Barajas'
airport--I'm very amuse by the
name of that airport all of the
time;
"barajas"
means "playing
cards," but Barajas is
simply the name of the town in
which the airport was built.
Anyone who has been to Spain,
especially to Madrid-Barajas'
airport knows that Sancho has
won the wager,
for there are hundreds of
painted and sculpted figurines
of Don Quixote and Sancho or
every kind for sale,
including mouse pads for
computers, believe me.
In fact, the statues of Don
Quixote and Sancho graze the
Plaza de España in
Madrid.
If you have been to Madrid,
you have seen them,
I'm sure, if you have not,
when you do,
you will go see them,
I'm sure, too.
We have several images of them.
I believe that Spain is the
only country in which there are
statues of fictional characters.
I don't think that there is a
statue of the Pilgrim in Dante's
Commedia in Italy,
as far as I know,
or of Hamlet,
in England,
as far as I know.
It's quite remarkable.
Such has been the
identification of the
Quixote with Spain.
Spanish culture and the Spanish
language,
that, as we shall see a bit
later, some of its modern
writers,
some of the modern Spanish
Unamuno, have even spoken of
the religion of quixotism,
"religión del
quijotismo."
There we are.
Cervantes knew that his
protagonist would be one with
those of classical times;
a heady assumption for an
artist of the sixteenth and
seventeenth century whose
reverence for classical art was
immense.
I don't know if he could have,
of course, foreseen that there
would be a statue of his
protagonists in his town of
Madrid.
It is a realization,
that is, of the importance of
his characters,
particularly of Don Quixote,
based on the accomplishment of
his hero,
which, as I haven been saying,
is quite different from those
of the likes of Aeneas.
Don Quixote returns a conqueror
of himself, says Sancho,
as they enter their village;
and I quote now from our
translation--page 933:
"Open thine arms,
and receive likewise [he is
addressing the unnamed village
as they come into the town]
thy son Don Quixote,
who, if he comes conquered by
another's hand,
yet he comes a conqueror of
himself,
which, as I have heard him say,
is the greatest victory that
can be desired!"
Unquote.
This is Don Quixote's greatest
triumph.
What does this mean?
At the most literal level,
it means that he has accepted
his defeat at the hands of the
Knight of the White Moon
gracefully,
and is willing to abide by the
rules agreed upon before combat
with that Knight of the White
Moon.
In that way,
he has conquered himself,
but it may also mean what I
have suggested,
that the Knight of the White
Moon is a reflection of Don
Quixote himself,
hence, that he has been
vanquished by his own
projection,
by himself.
I think that,
more broadly speaking,
it means that Don Quixote has
come to know himself better,
and accept himself for what he
is;
that he has vanquished within
him his madness,
or he's about to.
As we heard in the quotation
about Helen and Dido this has
not been quite accomplished yet;
he talks about defeating Paris.
But we have also seen that,
since the Cave of Montesinos
episode,
Don Quixote has been dealing
differently with reality and
with himself,
so his return is a triumphant
one, according to Sancho.
There is also an echo here of
the Greek "know
thyself"
that Don Quixote has vanquished
himself because he has come to
really know himself.
So we finally come to the end.
We should begin by pondering,
why ends or endings are so
important?
Let me summarize what Frank
Kermode says in his beautiful
book The Sense of an
Ending, from 1966.
I will get to a long quotation
from that book that you have in
a handout with the bibliographic
information about the book by
Kermode.
By now, he's Sir Frank Kermode;
he's an Englishman who was
knighted by the Queen;
an excellent critic,
one of the better,
perhaps the best critic of the
English language,
although I see that tremulously
because if Harold Bloom hears
that I have said something like
that,
my life may be in danger.
Every time I leave this class,
or another class,
I encounter Harold Bloom who
yells at the top of his lungs,
"Oh Roberto,
here comes the second best
critic at Yale!"
meaning that he,
of course, is the first to
which I answer,
"Harold,
we belong to different
generations and you belong to
the one that is past."
There is a right to defend
oneself, even from this Knight
of the White Moon.
All of us, in the modern era,
think that we live in a world
of crisis;
that is at the end of an epoch
and the beginning of the next.
Hence, we are keenly concerned
with the sense of what we
perceive as the impending end.
The sense that it can give to
the past--the sense that that
end can give to the past,
and to the future.
The fictions that we create
reflect this anxiety and are
designed to show "the
concord of the middest,"
which is what Kermode calls our
condition,
man or women in the middest,
in the middle;
this middest that we inhabit,
with beginnings and ends.
These fictions,
in which there is this
relationship between beginning
and end our Kermode calls
"fictions of concord."
There seems to be,
according to him,
a human need to relate
beginnings to ends,
even if we are not religious
believers,
or believers in secular version
of Providence,
like Marxism.
Providence, from
providere,
means foresight,
to--but mostly,
providence means the care of a
benevolent God who guides our
lives and our steps.
"Apocalypse"
is one of the fictions of
concord;
it ends, transforms and is
concordant.
"Apocalypse"
is from the Greek "to
uncover,"
which means revelation,
hence the Book of Revelation,
the last in the New Testament.
Prophecy is another form;
it tells us the shape of the
future;
it connects the present with
that end and beyond.
We are born in the middle,
and, according to Kermode:
"to make sense of our span
we need effective concords with
origins and ends,
such as give meanings to lives
and to poems."
Unquote.
Millenarianism,
the end is near--you have seen
all of these cartoons of the
guys holding the cardboard
saying the end is near,
repent, and so
forth--millenarianism has to do
with a thousand years,
with something lasting a
thousand years,
like those who believe that the
end of the world would come in
the year 1000,
and some even in the 2000.
If you remember,
back in 2000 there were all
kinds of prophecies.
Of course, all of these people
who prophesized are quick to
recalculate.
If it doesn't happen,
they recalculate.
It wasn't in the year 1000;
it was since the death of
Christ, 1033,
I mean, they always
recalculate.
The year 2000 came and went,
and many people were waiting
for all kinds of catastrophes to
happen.
Chiliasm is another word you
should remember.
"Chiliastic"
from the Greek for one thousand
is the belief that Christ will
rise in 1,000 years.
So we have beginning,
man or woman in the middest,
and end, and in the long quote
that I will read now from
Kermode this is how he explains
in a very charming way:
"Let us take a very simple
example, the ticking of a clock.
We ask what it says:
and we agree that it says
tick tock.
[Of course, this is only in
English.
In Spanish it goes 'tic,
tac,' but in any event,
since we are speaking English
it's 'tick tock'].
By this fiction we humanize it,
making it talk our language.
Of course, it is we who provide
the fictional difference between
the two sounds:
tick is our word for a
physical beginning,
tock our word for an end.
We say they differ.
What enables them to be
different is a special kind of
middle.
We can perceive a duration only
when it is organized.
It can be shown by experiment
that subjects who listen to
rhythmic structures,
such as tick-tock
repeated identically,
can reproduce the intervals
within the structure accurately,
but they cannot grasp
spontaneously the interval
between the rhythmic groups
[that is,
the rhythmic group is
"tick-tock,"
okay?
each group is
"tick-tock";
so they cannot spontaneously
grasp the interval between
rhythmic groups,
that is, between
"tock,"
and "tick,"
where the next group begins;
Okay: "Tick-tock,"
Mmm, "Tick-tock";
so "tock--tick," okay?
If anyone came in,
and listened to me now,
would certainly conclude that I
have gone bonkers;
that Don Quixote's madness is
really contagious].
The first interval is organized
and limited
["tick-tock"]
and the second is not.
According to Paul Fraise [I
don't know who it is]
the tock-tick gap is
analogous to the role of the
'ground' in spatial perception
[that is, blurry and
undifferentiated];
each is characterized by a lack
of form, against which the
illusory organizations of shape
and rhythm are perceived in the
spatial or temporal object.
The fact that we call the
second of the two related sounds
tock is evidence that we
use fictions to enable the end
to confer organization and form
on the temporal structure.
The interval between the two
sounds, between tick and
tock is now charged with
significant duration.
The clock's tick-tock I
take to be the model for what we
call a plot, [the plot...]
an organization that humanizes
time by giving it form;
and the interval between
tock and tick
represents purely successive,
disorganized time of the sort
we need to humanize."
That's the end of this,
I think, very illustrative
quotation.
So, the end is meaning;
the end provides meaning,
and this is why it is so
necessary.
He goes on, Kermode:
"Men, in the middest,
make considerable imaginative
investments in coherent
patterns,
which by the provision of an
end make possible a satisfying
consonance,
with origins and with the
middle" Unquote.
The plots of our poems,
plays and novels reflect that
need for significant endings.
So what is the significance of
Don Quixote's ending,
or is it significant?
In the next to the last chapter
Sancho discards the omens that
Don Quixote sees in various
things and events,
as they come into the village,
omens which will connect the
end of the novel with a future
beyond it;
they are prophetic.
I'm quoting from 934:
"'Malum signum,
malum signum! [this is
Latin;
"bad sign,
bad sign]
A hare flies;
dogs pursue her,
Dulcinea appears not!'"
Says Don Quixote.
Remember the hare that is
running and that Sancho actually
catches because she's so tired,
it's so tired.
In the Spanish Don Quixote
actually says:
"Liebre huye,
galgos la siguen:
¡Dulcinea no
parece!"
Jarvis has given it syntax,
which in Spanish it does not
have.
Don Quixote has abandoned
syntax and appears to speak in
tongues,
as if he were having a vision
or a revelation,
which is what he's trying to
find in this bad omen,
this malum signum that
he sees.
The incident shows that,
in his subconscious,
is still in the world of dreams
and of literature where these
concords occur.
The prophetic would extend that
world for closing and ending.
But, as I said,
Sancho dismisses,
but Sancho dismisses these
omens in a very wise way,
appealing to Christian
doctrine.
It is as if Cervantes himself
were, here, wavering about how
to end the novel.
But, what is the meaning of the
end Cervantes does give the
novel?
There are in the Quixote
three forms of potential
closure.
Cervantes closes the
Quixote in three ways.
First, Don Quixote is defeated;
second, he regains his sanity;
third, he dies.
One could say that this scheme
points to a three-part tied
conception of reality or of the
worlds in which Don Quixote
lives with each form of closure
corresponding to each of the
three.
I've given you a handout with a
kind of crass primitive
representation of these three
worlds as concentric circles
that I made myself,
and this is why--and it shows
it--but I hope that it is clear
enough.
First, the fictional world of
chivalry, Don Quixote is
defeated.
This is the realm of books.
Second, present day reality Don
Quixote returns to being Alonso
Quijano, the Good.
Third, Don Quixote dies,
and presumably reaches the true
reality, that is,
the afterlife.
Hence, life itself was like a
fiction, in that it was
ephemeral and made up of things
of dubious substance.
It's a self contained,
one could say,
fiction of concord.
A possible fourth form of
closure, at a meta-fictional
level, would be that the defeat
of Avellaneda's apocryphal
Quixote.
But let us go over the three in
more detail.
First, the fictional world of
chivalry.
Don Quixote is defeated by the
Knight of the White Moon,
hence his quest comes to an end
within his madness and within
the fiction of chivalric
romances.
But as I said in the last
class, and I said a few minutes
ago,
there are signs that the Knight
of the White Moon is like a
reflection of Don Quixote
himself or of his madness,
and, more profoundly,
of that nothingness,
that was his very fragile
being, his very fragile self.
This is why this Knight is
White almost transparent,
a ghost of Don Quixote.
So this defeat within the world
of books announces or prefigures
his regaining his sanity,
and even announces his death,
as white suggests nothingness,
hence, it suggests death.
Then, there is present day
reality;
Alonso Quijano regains his
sanity.
It is like a conversion story.
The conversion story is
typically a man who--
the old man dies,
and the new man is reborn,
that is, a conversion story,
so there is a death and
resurrection involved.
Don Quixote sleeps and awakens
changed,
as if he had undergone a
mystical experience,
similar to the sleep and
awakening after the Cave of
Montesinos episode,
which prefigured this one.
How can he know that he has now
awakened to his true self and
real world?
Don Quixote had the memory of
who he had been,
but if his life as Don Quixote
is now complete,
and his life is about to be
complete,
his life as Alonso Quijano,
what differentiates the two?
This is the conundrum of
Segismundo in Calderón's
Life is a Dream,
that play that it have
recounted to you several times
where the young prince is
drugged,
taken to the palace,
he commits all kinds of crimes,
he's drugged,
taken back to the tower,
and he awakes,
and he can't tell if it was a
dream what he experienced in the
palace,
or if he's now dreaming in the
tower, he can't tell.
So Segismundo's answer in
Calderón's play is to cut
through the ambiguity,
and will himself to be good,
to be good because life may be
a dream,
but it may be a rehearsal for a
life that is more enduring.
Now, the afterlife,
that outer circle.
Don Quixote's death,
he dies, by the way,
I don't know if you have taken
notice of this,
but he dies unmarried and
without succession,
which is evident in the scene
with the notary when he's
dictating his testament,
because he has to leave
everything to his niece and
friends and so forth.
Again, it is very much like
Segismundo's awakening to the
dream like quality of life
itself.
It is as if all of life were
like a dream,
his madness was a dream within
that dream, and death the only
access to a true permanent life.
Hence, it is not only his
madness that is like a dream,
but everything else.
His madness is a dream within a
dream.
Only death can put an end to
the play of reflections,
and in a way this is why Alonso
Quijano has to die.
Don Quixote's death is the last
in a series of mock deaths that
have appeared throughout the
book and prefigured this one;
one at the end of Part I,
when he's knocked unconscious;
then, of course,
in the Cave of Montesinos.
Don Quixote's death is the last
in a series of mock deaths,
as I have said.
One has to take into account
that the death of Don Quixote,
at least within the plot of the
novel, is also a kind of return.
Don Quixote returns home to the
heimlich,
to use Freud's word,
to the familiar,
to the place where he was
Alonso Quijano,
where he was sane.
This makes the entire series of
episodes that make up the whole
book his madness like a bubble,
or a dream all the more so.
It is like the Barataria
episodes are to Sancho,
another dream.
Repetitions of this kind lead
one to consider the fiction in
between as something that one
could dispense with.
Do the events within that
bubble occur in some sort of
concert with one another,
or are they themselves just a
series of repetitions?
Is there a successive sense to
the novel's plot?
Is there a sequential quality
to the novel,
a temporal--a temporality in
the Quixote that leads to
that end?
For instance,
we have been able to more or
less follow the months,
and perhaps even the days,
during which the adventures
take place;
but, is there a sense of
temporality, of chronology,
of inevitability?
We know that he has to return
at some point to the village,
as he did before,
and once he's defeated we know
that his madness is now on the
wane.
There is inevitably in the
transience of his madness,
of this invention of self,
and of his very life.
On the other hand,
a close reading of the last
chapter does not reveal anything
about the death of Cide Hamete
Benengeli, for instance.
When did Cide Hamete Benengeli
die?
There is no total closure in
the Quixote possible.
I think Cervantes plays with it
ironically;
he knows that no matter how may
times he says Don Quixote is
dead,
and that Cide Hamete is hanging
his pen and addressing his pen,
that any writer can still come
up as Juan Montalvo did--
I think I may have mentioned
him before--
an Ecuatorian writer,
who wrote a wonderful book
called Chapters of the
Quixote that Cervantes
Forgot;
and it's a pastiche,
meaning it's imitating
Cervantes's style.
So Cervantes knows--and we will
talk about that when we talk
about Pierre Menard,
the story by Borges in our next
class.
The Quixote is not a
book that has a plot in the
Aristotelian sense with a
beginning,
a middle, and an end,
all tied together tightly in a
sequence of events leading a
finish.
It is the life of Don Quixote
that gives it form,
as in the picaresque the life
of the pícaro
gives form to the narrative,
and we can think here,
again, of what Ginés de
Pasamonte said jokingly about
not finishing his book because
his life is unfinished,
poking fun at that
autobiography as a convention.
The book has to end with his
death;
death is a form of closure that
everyone understands;
it gives life shape.
Quevedo, Francisco de Quevedo,
a great poet of the seventeenth
century.
I urge you to read Quevedo,
and one way to do so is to tell
you that he wrote some of the
most obscene poems in the
history of the Spanish language,
also some of the most beautiful
love poems.
Perhaps--Borges said that
Quevedo was a whole literature
all by himself.
He has a poem about death in
which he ends by saying that
death will organize his life,
will give it meaning.
So death provides an end toward
which everything will seem to
have been pointing.
Aristotelian plots are
artificial.
The ones that will be
"tick-tock,"
unless you believe that there
is a tight concert to the world
and to history,
or unless you begin to believe
in Providence.
In this sense,
Cervantes is showing that the
novel,
as a form, cannot be bound by
these artificial shapes of art,
like the epic,
and like tragedy,
but by the shape of life as
everyone understands it;
ort of a baggy monster that he
has created in the novel.
This is profoundly so when we
take into account that
Cervantes' own death is near,
as he writes about Don
Quixote's death,
and we will be talking about
Cervantes' death in the next
class.
This is also the reason why
there is, for instance,
no closure to the story of Ana
Félix,
Ricote's daughter.
One may ask,
also, why there is so little
about Don Quixote's birth and
youth?
One could say that the only
life of Don Quixote that is
worth knowing is his life as the
mad knight, that everything else
is of little consequence.
So it is the life that Don
Quixote offered for himself that
is important in the conception,
execution and structure of the
book,
but it is a life,
not a completed action in the
Aristotelian sense.
Why not end the book then by
making him sane?
A sane Don Quixote would close
the plot of Don Quixote's
meta-life, his life as art and
literature.
One answer would be to say that
only by making him die can
Cervantes blur the distinction
between our daily lives and the
invented lives of literature,
both have endings with
significance.
So Don Quixote's death as Don
Quixote and his rebirth as
Alonso Quijano is not enough to
close the book;
he also had to die,
but only if the theme of the
book is,
and I believe that it is,
the unreality of worldly life,
and our hope for a real life
after death.
Now, I'm going to just mention
what some authors,
major authors,
said about the shape of the
Quixote, since we can look
at it as a whole shape,
and I will then get to the
author I mentioned before,
Miguel de Unamuno.
I may have mentioned him
before, I mentioned certainly
Ortega y Gasset,
who was the great Spanish
philosopher of the twentieth
century.
Miguel de Unamuno was a
philosopher, but also a writer,
a novelist, a poet,
a thinker in general.
He was the rector or president
of the University of Salamanca,
what we would call today a
public intellectual.
He was exiled by the
dictatorship of Primo de Rivera
and he wrote--
he was a Basque,
born in Bilbao in 1864,
and died in Salamanca in 1936,
just at the beginning of the
Spanish Civil War.
You may have heard the titles
of some his books,
Del sentimiento
trágico de la vida,
On the Tragic Sense of
Life, a book that I
recommend that you read,
La agonía de
cristianismo,
The Agony of Christianity,
and a very, very well known
novel called Niebla,
Mist, from 1914.
In 1905 Unamuno published
Vida de Don Quijote y Sancho,
The Life of Don Quixote and
Sancho,
which is a commentary,
chapter by chapter,
of the Quixote,
a very sui generis kind
of commentary.
Unamuno liked to be outrageous.
For instance,
Unamuno says that he believes,
or feigns to believe,
in the real existence of Don
Quixote and Sancho,
claiming that Cervantes a
mediocre writer by a stroke of
luck got to write the story
written about the pair by one
Cide Hamete Benengeli;
so this is his conceit.
So he riles against Cervantes.
For Unamuno there is no
assurance that Don Quixote will
find a life after death.
This is talking about the death
of Don Quixote,
stressing that,
perhaps, this life is all there
is, and that it is like God's
dream;
so he hopes that God will go on
dreaming us, he says,
humorously, because,
if he stops dreaming,
we will all disappear along
with the universe.
God gave us the desire to be
immortal,
like him, and created a symbol
of it in Don Quixote,
who does what he does because
he wants to be immortal,
and so Unamuno mourns Don
Quixote's passing and riles
against Cervantes for
trivializing his death,
and he affirms that,
at least, Don Quixote passed on
his madness to Sancho.
You remember in the last scene,
there, where Sancho says,
don't die, please,
let us go on now!
And so it is Sancho who will
carry on with the madness.
Unamuno goes on to say that
Antonia Quijana,
the niece, does marry a
sensible boring man who never
heard of chivalric romances,
so therefore she inherits,
and she forces him to live a
humdrum life devoid of
adventure.
Be the kind of husband who
takes out the garbage,
but takes no risks.
Dulcinea, however,
or Aldonza Lorenzo,
on the other hand does
understand her elevation to
ideal lady,
and she leads men to heroic
action,
that is, the ideal of such a
lady leads men to ideal action
meaning to take risks.
She and Sancho keep alive,
according to Unamuno,
the religion of Don Quixote,
which is on the wane in Spain,
as he writes his book in 1905.
He complains:
"With Spain having been
defeated in the Spanish-American
War by the United States."
For him, this defeat signals
the end of quijotismo,
this having been defeated by
this upstart nation,
and he longs for a return of
the quixotic spirit to Spain,
one that rebels against
commonplace reality and abhors
mediocrity and submissiveness.
He belonged to the so called
Generation of '98,
which is a collection of
writers, a group of writers,
who all wrote about the
miseries of Spain at the turn of
the century,
and particularly complaining
about the defeat at the hand of
the United States.
There is a moment in the
Spanish-American War that I call
a quixotic moment,
and it is the following;
this is to what degree a
country can absorb a fictional
writer: Admiral Pasqual Cervera
y Topete,
Cervera is the last name you
want to--
got himself trapped with the
whole Spanish fleet in Santiago
de Cuba Bay.
Santiago's Bay,
in Cuba, like all Cuban bays,
has the virtue of being very
broad and with a very narrow
entrance.
Cervera got into the bay with
all of his ships,
which are wooden,
old fashioned,
and guns that didn't have much
range.
The American fleet positioned
itself outside waiting for the
inevitable moment when Cervera
either gave up or tried to
leave.
Cervera communicated with
Spain, they had cable at the
time,
about his predicament,
and the Spanish government
answered saying,
"We know that with your
valor,
vigor and all of your
intelligence and cunning you
will be able to prevail.
We order you to come out."
So the Spanish fleet came out,
and it was a turkey shoot.
The American fleet shot every
single one of the Spanish ships.
Cervera writes about this;
I've read his memoirs,
that he was very satisfied that
at least the Americans pulled
him out of the water;
he went down with the ship.
The Americans pulled him out of
his water,
with is sword and everything,
put him on board,
and treated him with great
difference and sent the
surviving--
the few surviving sailors were
sent as prisoners of war to
Maine for a while,
where he was able to visit them
later.
Cervera was later sued by the
Spanish government for losing
the fleet;
so that was a quixotic moment
of the kind Unamuno would have
applauded.
So much for Unamuno.
Borges, Jorge Luis Borges,
we're going to speak more about
him in our next class;
he wrote a marvelous essay
about the last chapter of the
Quixote.
He points out that,
I think I've mentioned this
before, that the one quality
that unites Don Quixote and
Alonso Quijano is courage;
that Alonso Quijano faces death
with courage and serenity.
So this is the one quality that
they have in common,
even if one is sane and the
other one is mad.
He writes that:
"Cervantes could have
chosen a more astonishing
episode to bring about Don
Quixote's return to sanity,
but chose sleeping,
that mysterious world from
which we return when we awaken
not knowing where we have
been."
This is what Borges picks up on
those six hours of sleep,
that those six hours of sleep
are like death,
so that Don Quixote dies and is
resurrected as Alonso Quijano.
Borges remarks on the sort of
what calls "lateral and
casual way,"
in which Don Quixote dies at
the end of a sentence.
If you have followed the
ending, there it's sort of at
the end of the sentence but,
"I mean that he
died";
"Quiero decir que...
murió;
and he writes:
"It is the last of many
cruelties that Cervantes has
visited upon his hero.
Perhaps this cruelty is a form
of modesty and Cervantes and Don
Quixote understand each other
well and forgive each
other."
Writes Borges.
Borges claims that the whole
book was written for this last
scene of death.
I am going to finish with the
image that you have on the title
page of your syllabus which is,
of course, the one by Pablo
Picasso,
whom you all know,
of course, was a Spanish
painter,
although he lived in France
most of his life and all of
that,
but he was a Spanish painter
born in Málaga in 1881,
and died in 1973.
I left Picasso for last.
His Quixote,
as I said, and as you know,
is on the title page of your
syllabus.
I think that Picasso's
Quixote is so schematic
because he considers him an
archetype, and archetypes are
schematic by nature.
Notice, of course,
the skeletal Rocinante,
is made up of lines,
the plump Sancho,
and the donkey's ears.
I think that the donkey's ears
are their signature,
and in Spanish
"burro"
means a "donkey,"
and it means someone who's
dumb.
So you can, you know?
You point ears like and it
says, you're a donkey.
So this is why the donkey's
ears are so prominent.
Picasso has injected some humor
in his painting,
which I think is quite
appropriate.
The windmills in the background
are Don Quixote's signature,
and the bright sun beating down
on him is Castile's hot sun,
which is present through much
of the novel,
but what is not so evident,
it seems to me,
until you look for a while,
is that Don Quixote's figure is
like an interrogation mark;
the figure of Don Quixote is
like an interrogation mark,
a question mark,
in English, I'm sorry,
I'm translating from Spanish,
"punto de
interrogación,"
question mark.
Your languages tend to get
mixed up;
there are advantages and
disadvantages to knowing several
languages.
So I'll leave you with that
question mark of Picasso's.